ja ich möchte diese frage stellten user
zeigen vom kleinen er einen globalen
perspektive zu eröffnen und zunächst mal
zum digitalen wandel insgesamt an
hochschulen mit aktuell entschieden eine
etwas kritischere zum einstieg zu nehmen
und 33 richtige gestaltungs fehler die
ich sehe eine epische vertiefen nun
einmal seine taktischen konzepte dann
und strategische verankerung das passt
sehr gut in ihrem kreis hier bei den
multiplikatoren und multiplikatoren auf
den botschafter nie gehört habe dann
hoffe ich sehr gut denn sie sind
diejenigen die den change angels
vielleicht sind es heute gestellt
gestaltungs fertig sind die
eingangsbereiche open application und
natürlich zu stoff mit einem fazit ende
möchte ich ja bei dem titel eines
vortrags im digitalen zeitalter
vielleicht gesehen um einen titel schon
am hochschul vor und digitalisierung
orientieren und die haben jetzt 20 16 in
ihrem abschlussbericht dass noch etwas
weniger explizit mit dem titel turn und
bildung im digitalen zeitalter und ich
werde gerne zu beginn darauf schauen ja
ist das wirklich eine sensation ein
körperlicher paradigmenwechsels wird ja
oft von digitalen transformation wird
viel gesprochen und ich würde darin von
einige studien einen kritischen blick
erstmal warten
jetzt können wir sagen netz das sehr
motivierend wenn er vielleicht eine
ernüchternde ergebnis bei rauskommt dann
eher in cannes motivation ist ganz
wichtig ich mache das auch wirklich vor
dem hintergrund dass ich denke man muss
hingegen entstand
es ist sinnvoll der nüchternen blick zu
haben um dann zu sagen hier kann ich
weiterhin und gestalten und einen die
herausforderungen im wasser neueren
studien gehen und endlich kann man also
ich bin 35 uhr heranziehen studie gerade
wird von zwei wochen erschienen ist
wir haben stand der digitalisierung
global sozusagen vom hochstand versuch
zu erfassen den monitoren die bildung 20
17 der bertelsmann-stiftung studie und
eine fläche die auch im rahmen des forum
digitalisierung entstanden ist und aus
dem sherwood eine pflegen oder cad und
studenten entstanden ist ein perfekter
und 22 16
zu den ganz wichtigen punkt aus meiner
sicht lernen mit digitalen medien und
studentischer perspektive zunächst
einmal genehmigt
anscheinend unbedingt weil ich in dieser
szene sonst von der forderung des
lernens mit digitalen medien schon sehr
lange unterwegs finden und
interessanterweise genau dem ersten
projekt an sich die ausgeführt haben
und es sei jetzt einfach so zwang
eingestiegen bin in diese
auseinandersetzung konnte von daher den
prozess 20 jahre schritt fasst begleitet
das wird gedacht habe ich ja nun bekomme
ich bei meinen beispielen erlaube ich
mir einfach ein beispiel aus meiner
eigenen praxis über die jahre so heran
zu ziehen
ja wenn man sich anguckt es denn dass
der einsatz lernen digitalen medien an
hochschulen gefördert worden in
deutschland dann sieht man eigentlich
über die jahre sehr menge
förderprogrammen gelaufen in
unterschiedlichen abständen hier
übrigens noch mal die vorher ich beim
noch in form einer kollegin der frau
kilo sind immer der arme tier auf
stefanie wm-pokal
ja man kann die das eigentlich braucht
so ein fall
dass die ersten förderungen der stadt
waren und wie taktische konzept
beinhaltet mit digitalen medien anders
zu gestalten also sonst ist eine neue
innovative produkte von den didaktischen
konzepten
dann setzt der nächste teil der
förderung geben er auch strukturen
schaffen und darauf besteht dann nochmal
genauer eingehen warum das notwendig ist
und alle auseinandersetzung mit
einzelnen weniger zwischen konzerten
begleiten sollte ja und die in den
letzten jahren und auch jetzt und
gegenwärtig sozusagen hochstadt lehre
kann man verständigte förderung sicher
auch die gesamte integration mit
initiativen zu gewähren unschuldig
taktik insgesamt wenn man ein stück aus
kleinen welche förderung war - besonders
in den letzten jahren
da sieht man auch noch mal dieser
aspekte strukturelle verankerung und
worauf ich gehe dann noch
ich möchte dieses change prozesses
musste als multiplikatorinnen und
multiplikatoren teil davon sind da geht
es eben darum dass das lernen mit
digitalen medien auch strategisch
stadtwerken sollte also die hochschule
strategien und weitere förderprogramme
wir wissen natürlich auch im wissen was
wir tun und mit welchem willkommen also
die ganze zwei jungen zur forschung in
diesem bereich und die förderung von
auch wenn endlich echten resources also
dem schirm und er eine bildungs
verschlossen später auch noch mal
genauer ausführen
hier aber nicht den anforderungen
anschaut dann würde man ja eigentlich
erst mal denken das ist ja stimmt ja das
ist eine ganz menge forderungen
eingegangen was die effekte ein kleines
zwischenfazit oder zwischenergebnis 2009
um sich den kollegen und den normalen
die mühe gemacht
wedekind und haben muss und vor allem
der genau anschauen welche projekte gibt
es dennoch und welche konzepte
entwickelt worden sind innovative
lernszenarien sind dennoch auffinden und
haben festgestellt
die hälfte hat sozusagen adresse nicht
gefunden also hat es kurz zu fassen
gemacht die nachhaltigkeit überhaupt
nicht gegeben die menschen baut gleich
nicht mehr dahin kollege gegangen so das
heißt an dieser stelle hat man deutlich
erkennt man braucht noch etwas
zusätzlich ist es reicht nicht nur ein
gelungenes durchdachtes medien
didaktisches konzept umzusetzen
ja wenig nachhaltig die nicht
übertragbar und hat auch dazu geführt
dass in deutschland die verbreitung
der freien willens ressourcen sehr
internet im vergleich sehr zurück stand
weil auch hier strukturell wenig bedacht
wurde oder wenig erreicht und was nicht
den großen wert der einzelnen projekte
spieler sollen selbstverständlich nicht
ja und das feuer letzten untersuchung
von 2009 seit zehn jahren ist das ganze
heer
es kann jetzt ganz anders sein wenn man
sich jetzt an content dlc de/studien
bernd venohr 20 18
mehr wenn ihr doch herausgekommen womit
wird im moment kurz zusammengefasst mit
dieser welt nizza die technologien im
hochsprung nicht pathetisch eingebunden
als auch auf 20 18 kommt eine studie zu
diesem ergebnis ein kleines zitat daraus
die menschen heute
er kocht über
dabei sehr schöne technologies and
certain points aus der oberschicht also
26 das wird noch mal gesagt wir sind
eigentlich immer noch in großem maßstab
in der experimentiert worden
ja wenn man eine andere stelle kommt der
an einem monitor digitale bildung 21 17
von der bergman stiftung erschienen was
sie dank ergebnisse ich will nicht alles
durchgehen aber wichtig ist dass ein
kernergebnis auch hier didaktische
potenziale werden nicht völlig
ausgeschöpft
wir sind weit entfernt glaube ich von
dem was die cic und digitalen
informationen immer so schillernd
verspricht bleibt noch etwas zu tun
und genauso und bezogen auf die auf die
bildungschancen kann man ganz klar
feststellen dass der umgang mit den
da materialien immer noch einzelfall
orientiert sein erfolg und einfach viele
strukturelle in bösel noch damals eine
dritte studie aus studierenden
perspektive verpflichten besonders
interessant weil er mit vorbildern
sprachen ja auch davon dass sie auch
richtig ist wir haben eine andere
generation jetzt von studierenden an
hochschulen
denn die sind so nelles gewöhnt mit
digitalen gegen umzugehen aber wenn man
jetzt mal genauer punkt also diese
ausgekoppelte stücke aus dem single
ranking hat ihm auch interessante
ergebnisse gebracht und auch eltern mit
ergebnissen tigers ganzen präsentieren
ein ernüchterndes bild zeichnen also die
wichtigen ergebnisse dass man erst mal
selber kann dass die jetzige studierende
generation zwei digitale medien nutzt an
ganz vielen stellen im alter aber das
ist das überhaupt nicht notwendig auf
ihr lernen und bildungsfreiheit
zusammen oder auch möglich an
hochschulen überträgt das eigentlich ein
kurzschluss ist zu sagen dafür zunächst
und jetzt ist das automatisch einen
digitale medien schneller leichter
akzeptiert und deswegen auch auf und
landet das einschlägige immerhin 20 16
dass gesagt wird diese teenager aus dem
eis plakative benutzt wird
den muss man eigentlich viel da muss man
viel differenzierter hinschauen und sich
das viel kritischer sehen und auch
bezahlt und ist denn die tiere urteilte
die gesamtsituation ist digitale medien
sind an vielen hochschulen kein
integraler bestandteil der lehre also
das ist auch jetzt noch zu okay wenn man
in dieser studie sind genauer ermöglicht
der tiefen berger und mit welchen
so identifizieren diese ganz plakativ
benannt haben und auch der auf der
linken seite die pdf nutzen also darauf
ja auch schnell passiert wenn man also
wenn die ersten antiken denken dass bei
pdfs italien entstehen waren in dieser
untersuchung über noch die am meisten
ausgeprägten dann die kategorie
diejenigen die hebt schon bei die
centerin form digitale prüfungs formate
genutzt haben
die video konsumierenden ist selbst der
anderen typ definiert wurde und
diejenigen die man eigentlich erwarten
könnte wenn man das konzept der digital
and if star weiter denkt die digitalen
raum haben uns in dieser studie genannt
wurden sind wir in der geringsten
ausprägung hier fanden und das war eine
relativ umfangreiche studentische
befragung der studierenden dann ist noch
interessanter in zusammenfassen
verbergen das nutzungsverhalten anrufen
in balance kontext eher konservativ und
sehr wichtigster unterschied
die gleichen fächer nach den
unterschiedlichen hochschulen waren
differenzen also sehr geprägt von den
angeboten und von der anforderung der
jeweiligen universitäten gut damit will
ich mache diesen kleinen lichtern
endlich verlassen gefunden sagen an
dieser stelle ich glaube ich hier
starten wir das heißt es ist immer
einiges zu tun und ich sehe mit wie
verschiedene herausforderungen und
gestaltungs fair und wird jetzt auf drei
mal musste werdet ein gegenbeispiel die
taktische konzepte denke es ihrem
erklärt wie sie bei der wollte am tag
einige vorstellen als multiplikatorinnen
und multiplikatoren einige erfahrungen
gemacht hier sind auch die eine
ausgestellt forum digitalisierung werden
jetzt erst mal irgendwann wannemacher
und verschiedene typen unterschieden in
dem inneren kreis das klassische
anreicherung also präsentieren mit
digitalen medien anzureichern dass man
die integration oder er einen
schwerpunkt auf göttliche
online-angebote das sind die drei
szenarien sich in dieser systematik
gegenseitig ausschließen und in dem
außer umkreis dann die verschiedenen
szenarien mit dieser vision elementen
und simulation der stern und
personalisierung und ganz wichtig
interaktion kollaborationen also die
computerunterstützte digitalen
virtuellen zusammenarbeit
das hier ist mal das alte china
und daran kann man natürlich sehr viele
verschiedene didaktische szenario passen
und ich finde da mal was ganz das ist
schon ganz schön 96 der amerikanische
forscher noch ein ticket gesagt haben
die qualität des einsatzes von digitalen
medien in der bildung die wirklich
gemessen ob die digitalen medien um die
tunnel sind die werkzeuge benutzt werden
für einen verbesserten beschleunigten
transport und vertrieb von perspektive
einnimmt oder und dann
außerdem sei der transport perspektive
werden wir keine wirklichen mehrwert
kann sich verbessern und von
bildungsprozessen durch digitale medien
erhalten sondern eher wenn man einen
gemeinschaftsgeist der tiefe die sich
das ändert haben einen ring community
perspektiven die es ermöglicht den
lernenden den studierenden gestoßen
die forschen forschungs community zu
bekommen austausch untereinander zu
fördern in einem ganz anderen master es
ist im klassischen system möglich ist
und diese perspektive für mich
interessant und semestern kann man denke
ich auch heute noch gut an medien
didaktische konzepte anlegen
ja ich daran ein beispiel aus meiner
praxis dagegen ganz kurz wir haben an
der uni münchen in einem studienangebots
und ja der arbeit das in der nicht
besonders ist und das ist so große teile
75 prozent online
mit einem coolen gestaltet ist jetzt
könnte ich mir vorstellen
jetzt sollen die ersten sozialen bereich
das ist natürlich rom oft in der kritik
gelesen aber ich glaube wenn man das
geschickt macht dann kann man dieser
anwendungsbezogen durch die digitalen
gehen auch in dieses konzept zählen und
integriert werden das möchte ich ihnen
schon aufzeigen man sieht auch die
andere seite die digitalen medien in der
hochschule erlauben es eben auch an
zielgruppen anzusprechen dieses ein
studienangebot was die nachfrage im
sozialen sektor sehr gut abdeckt weil
wir haben uns sehr viele veranstaltungen
sozialen sektor nehmen keine
hochschulabschluss und wänden oder so
eine weiterqualifizierung akademischen
rahmen nicht weitermachen in ihren
berufen kann entweder angehen und das
damit decken wir in so einem
studienangeboten natürlich den ganz
wichtigen mitternacht im sozialen feld
zulassungsvoraussetzung ist hier eine
schlichte großer fan
sie beleuchtet als er den rezepten
präsenz und online phasen wir nutzen das
tatsächlich learning management system
in diesem fall oder wir haben mit
optionalen die jungen ferencz systemen
nutzen und das zeichen leicht in kürze
die was wir arbeiten portfolios und mit
einem werkzeug der politikberatung coco
mit
ja sagt ich schon ist sind jetzt hier
entstehen neue studien chancen und es
ist zu beginn einfach gewesen dass der
sozialen arbeit statt kritisiert worden
weil man gesagt hat ja man das online
mit dem nicht viel zu stark
standardisiert wird es sich alles aus
dem kontext gerissen durchmachen eine
methode kann überhaupt richtig
die fähigkeit entwickelt werden und was
ist mit kultureller vielfalt geht die
nicht unter der mann dazu in online.de
ist ja ich denke und mittlerweile auf
dieser studie ganze zehn jahren dass ich
wirklich sagen dass wir das sicherlich
immer über alle aber in weiten teilen
strukturell diese lösten widerlegen
können mit zwei beispiele dazu geben wir
setzen zum beispiel eine kollegiale
weise anteil am erfolg bei den
studierenden der berufsbegleitend
studieren kollegiale beratung und kennen
vielleicht einige von und auf jeden die
psychologinnen und psychologen im
bereich eben eine reale heute ohne
externen kompetenzen und partitionen
oder so auskommen und sie kann ihnen
auch im online
unbesetzt darauf eine plattform com net
und die macht sich das zunutze dass
forschungsergebnisse zu computer
vermittelte kommunikation eben belegt
haben dass gerade das textbasierte
zeitversetzte medium in der online
beratung mich auch wachstumssektor
besondere werte waren können und dass
wir hier in der kollegiale beratung
umgesetzt ja was heißt das für unsere
studierenden nämlich setzen wird genau
dies ist ein
genau an dieser stelle studierende
reflektieren im fall kochen einzelfälle
mit diesem schema der premiere feierte
sie in späteren und der ist an dieser
stelle nicht so wichtig nehmen durch die
plattform da diese 10 und städte der
beratung zusammen unterstützt dass man
immer weiß wo man steht und welche lese
phase eingeläutet
aber vor allen dingen was hat das für
wird in diesem studium hier kommen
die erfahrungen der studierenden neben
den studenten ein und gleichzeitig
verfüge diese zwei jahren hatte sich die
studierenden haben durch ihre
berufstätigkeit und durch ihre durch das
hochschulstudium denn der ist immer die
gefahr dass der getrennte welten bleiben
aber genau dadurch geklappt ein studium
bringt mögliche bildungsprozesse voran
wenn das verbunden wird und diese beiden
lernorte und die reflektion fähigkeiten
ob es wirklich noch mal ganz anders
geübt und trainiert was auch interessant
dabei ist dass es auch punkte in meine
vorbild darin kurz heimischen fahren
es ist wirklich ein im denken als
erstrat rede vor jeder vortrag von
autonomie in diesem fall wartungskosten
sind wir als lehrer mit überhaupt nicht
vorhanden also das wird er auch zu den
sc nicht passen
und das heißt wir müssen uns auch als
eine verlassen bieten dennoch eine
bewertung machen man kann ich komme
gerne als auch
bewerten und es ist auch ein erst mal
ein und deckten einen loslassen so zu
sagen dass man als lehrende nicht in den
resten der beratungsgruppe winter frage
aber es funktioniert ein
unterschiedlicher unterschiedliche weise
und insbesondere auch ein
wissenstransfer dieses jahr eine
organisationen stand weil die
studierenden das kennen gelernt haben
dass eben auch in ihre organisation im
sozialrecht
einige bringen muss man sich auch schon
ein stück weit mehr in grenzen
also diese plattformen dieses system
könnte statt ihre der ob nach dem
studium müssen also das ändert ihr nicht
die lösung für diese bewertungsprobleme
wir haben die ganzen und
beratungsprozesse von bewertungen
entlassen wie gesagt wir sind gar nicht
dabei und setzen stattdessen über so
andere sind bei der tig landeskultur
sich vier semester und vier semestern
erstreckt da arbeiten wir mit kopflos
und die wiederum können dann hätte werte
dienen die helfen auffällig studierenden
denn noch mal so eine clique das ganze
studio aufzubauen und einem hochgefahren
sonst im studium zu erkennen nicht dass
es im einzelnen vorstellen aber ich
fange seinem element
portfolien mal die erlaubnis also das zu
zweit ins netz ist eine studentin dann
interview mit mir selbst auch das
multimediale dabei nutzen und so ihre
standortbestimmung ihr professionelles
verständnis es weiter verwendbar so dass
er an einer stelle auch sehr viele
verschiedene vorteile die solche
szenarien oder diese kombination aus
kollegialer beratung am main und dem
einsatz von portfolios bringen
mit blick auf die zeit etwas gut in das
zweite gestaltete geschenke eingangs
gesagt haben er braucht um einfach
der ganze prozess ist nicht nur gute
neue innovative wege taktische konzepte
umzusetzen sondern eingebettet es ihnen
damit vermutlich als multiplikatorinnen
und die kantoren ist neues eingebettet
geschäftsprozess an einer hochschule
verschiedene braucht veränderung der
lehrenden beinhaltet und man an
verschiedenen stellen ansetzen muss und
es eines der viel verwendeten modelle
diesem bereich der das hotel so
nachhaltig die veränderungen und sagt
euren zielsysteme strategien braucht
gesteigert stellt die taktische achten
wir sie eben gesagt haben
aber auch technischer im sinne von
benutzerfreundlichen plattform
bereitstellung von angemessener technik
aber auch dass es nicht zu unterschätzen
die ganzen innovationen sportlichen
rahmen und dem morgen also hinreichend
ressourcen austauscht das was sie glaube
ich wahrscheinlich extra songs mit ihrem
multiplikatorinnen 9 und applikatoren
projekt machen um wirkliche veränderung
in einer kultur zu bekommen und
eingebettet in ein gesamtes
organisationssystem ja und ich glaube
das change management hat man hier auf
dieser stufe modell her und die
dringlichkeit ihrer mutter spielt muss
die gesamte digitalisierung der
gesellschaft
die hände habe ich glaube dass für
deutliche potenziale an hochschulen wenn
digitalen sollte einfach solche gesucht
werden
und es ist auch wichtig jedem punkt
sechs schnelle erfolge setzte ich glaube
ich auch das was wir mit den
multiplikatoren in projekten sehr gute
abdecken dass man wirklich sehen kann
welche konzepte welche möglichkeiten
ergibt sich dann von oben immer auch
nach diesen studien
vielleicht denkt dieser rahmen ist dann
wieder in diesen change management
besprochen dann hat man die dritte frage
ist das wie fries aber das video habe
strategisch verein kann in denen
organisation unter allen fans und
dennoch der hat laut dieser stelle sind
wir an
nicht gute idee nicht mit den personen
weg geben und mit der forderung alles
ausläuft also diese konsolidierung das
ist auch eine der wesentlichen aufgaben
kurz vor unserem wunsch in münchen aus
dem eigentlich ganz klassisch dann so
dicht dass von den auch bei den vollen
raum vorgestellt
wir hatten eine ausgedehnte pionier von
den unterschiedlichsten fakultäten und
unterschiedliche konzepte eingesetzt
unterschiedlichste plattformen und
irgendwann würde sehr deutlich ich
brauchte da anja zentraler unterstützung
der gesamtorganisation einer klaren
strategie
das wurde in bestimmten von projekten
erarbeitet und auch eine größere
unterstützung einheit bei uns hat damals
genannt wird weil ich sofort ja und ihr
leben des social platzen wird es jetzt
in das ist genau dieser punkt
integration muss ich auch sehr begrüßen
dass das jetzt integriert wird in
meetings am gehören zur und lehre wieder
im zentrum innovative lehre die ganz eng
zusammenarbeiten
ja und das linzer unserer hochschule
stellt die unterschiedlichen
technologien bereisen aber wir wissen
alle hier die technik in sicht sind es
nicht sondern bringt auch genau das und
das mit fallbeispielen für die
lehrerinnen bereitet es auf der fläche
szenarien
der folgenreichen welchen fakultäten
kollegen mit welchen aktionen eingesetzt
werden so dass auch hier eine aus
verfolgen
das alles immer mit dem blick richtung
wirklichen farbe kommt ja dann würde ich
gerne das dritte gestaltungs fällt noch
kommentieren das dokumentations reihe
bildungsressourcen habe ich gerne sind
weil wir unseren münchner namen
verlassen bis in großer brocken wenn man
sich die sg dann kommt dieser stelle
bewerben kommt darin ist sehr deutlich
dass viele dieser fälle moment los ist
das von erziehung und bildung bildung
für alle und er kurzbeschreibungen zur
inklusiven twitter bekomme die endläufe
opportunities fonds und kann man sieht
hier einen rutsch und wirklich am
lebenslangen darin ja wenn man das genau
am kommt es vor dass nochmal durch mehr
und hat das ergänzt damit diese sind
über eine bewerbung gesprochen ima kennt
er schon längst schon prozent bei
technology brechen resources and
description modelle die scan fries
access exotik kommentieren und ich denke
ich wenn man das im großen maßstab sieg
wir werden den bildungsbedarf weltweit
gesehen nicht mit unserem klassischen
universitäten abdecken können noch den
der höheren schulbildung
wir brauchen flexible offene
sonst müsste glaube ich ihnen nützlich
wo ein campus entstehen und man darüber
liegt etwas weiter schweifen lässt
in der kurzfassung hier mal eine
realisation einer lasershow kollegen die
also da einfach auf das als großen
freundes ressource als großen
hoffnungsträger sieht ja ein weiteres
beispiel wir haben zusammen mit der
kollegen die lose hier auch im raum
nachher vortragen werden ja auch einen
großen offenen online hausgemacht um
dieses konzept der fein
bildungsressourcen der weiter in der
die deutsche politik voranzubringen und
ist das schöne daran ist das konzept
eine so dass wir gesagt haben es soll
der post solcher sondern auch ein
der hieß es darin also wieder verwendet
können und das erfolgt jetzt
insbesondere von unseren österreichische
kollegin ist die ganzen letzten jahre in
abgewandelter weiterentwickelter form
der sechs dieser kurs auch wirklich
genuss formen und hat so zusammen es ja
als wurde als streuner
bildungsressourcen sich weiterentwickelt
und in verschiedenen kontexten angesetzt
eingesetzt hier ein anderes beispiel wo
ich gerade in meinem bett gefallen
forschung aktiv bin keine die so
vielleicht auch ein bisschen an ein
begriff ist eine endliche berlin
die idee haben und das wird man von der
idee ist das etwas was ich als digitaler
wandel digitale transformation sehen
würde wirklich was anderes zu machen
nämlich funkstreife geflüchtete über 90
stellen aber nicht selber und anzubieten
sondern in mittlerer position zu gehen
und insbesondere ein personalisiertes
unterstützungsangebot darum zu schieben
und wir untersuchen jetzt zum beispiel
in dem projekt alle die diese
unterstützung funktioniert auch dieses
innovative modell ausgeht auch daran
sind eine ganze menge gestaltungs
probleme in den teils aber ja erst mal
ein wirklich neuer zugang wenn man
insgesamt schafft genug lernen schafft
das wahrscheinlich auch viele von ihnen
kennen das war vor fünf jahren liegen
für euphorie und lux werft hochschule
revolutionieren gegangen nicht mit ein
sondern
ins leere
das ist ja fast immer so eine neue
innovation alte wegen reklamierens durch
die beste wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie
dann der noch immer leer
und wenn man sich anguckt passiert mit
den links eigentlich was die produktion
erstmals öffnet die bildungslandschaft
gerade die forschungslandschaft und das
ist dadurch den wert für sich
aber wenn man sich genauer umschaut dann
nimmt sie an mitteilen dann hat man
einfach in das viel diskutierte soll die
story ist ncs phänomen
man hat mit eines getriebenen
abschlussquote und von allen länger das
ist noch viel wichtiger in verschiedenen
studien effekt man dass die meisten die
teilnehmen
bereits katholische abschluss erfahren
also muss eingesetzt werden für
beruflicher weise
und insofern ist das jetzt auch da
wieder der transformative gedanken ist
jetzt die hochschulen komplett
verwandeln denn ich nicht dass nicht
einfällt aber das was ich gesagt habe
eine passion von rohstahl
ok damit bekomme ich auch schon zu
meinen fachleute in diesem gesamten der
kleinen zeitreise durch die
verschiedenen phasen der förderung und
der verschiedenen projekten und in
dieser drei ausgewählten
gestaltungsfreude eigentlich ihnen sagen
meine tv markt stürzen
hochstätter und digital zeitalter
erhalten
große gestaltungsaufgabe verschiedenen
ebenen und die gegner das alles nicht
und ich habe ja gewusst manche
da sprechen von hochschulbildung
digitalen zeit weiter weil das finde ich
ist der neutrale der nüchterne begriff
als das den titel digital transformation
der nicht langweilig und es wäre eine
ganz andere diskussion wollen wir eine
völlig veränderte universität das ist
ständig steht nach einem anderen einen
anderen blatt ja wichtig und total
wichtig verschließen
im vorletzten sozusagen antikatholische
erkennt die digitale technik wird können
nicht unweigerlich zu dieser oder jener
positiven oder negativen veränderungen
der bildung ein solcher technik
determinismus würden verkennen dass auf
die akteure angekommen und veränderungen
der bildungsarbeit und einen wandel in
der nähe größeren herbeizuführen
und ich hoffe dass ich damit zum stift
motivation der bogen gespannt haben
nicht
ich habe erst deutlich es funktioniert
noch vieles nicht so ich glaube genau
sie als aktive akteure auf sie kommt es
an beiden diesen dingen
und als allererstes vielleicht dann auch
schon mal meine vorgängerin ein ich bin
bei der vorbereitung noch mal über
wrestling gestoßen der nati forscher der
da im forschungsprojekt vielleicht von
kindergarten hat und der normalen text
geschrieben hat give peace a chance
solche experimente werbelinie vier
elementen und darf muss man ja
vielleicht jetzt jetzt habe ich weil ich
kann mich an eine ente in diesem satz
und dem verschließen
aber ich finde dass man sich mal genau
anguckt was wir es nicht mit dem
training bestreiten windows player
empfangen entscheiden was wenn meine
unschuld extremisten vermutet von dem
singleplayer sind
nur in belgien und tschechien spanien
fantastic bahn bisher ältesten großes
kino um in experimenten and explore bis
es fertig bringen stellten bequem girl
impulse ja und damit möchte ich enden
und wünsche ich genau solche prozesse
kommt hier auf den 24
[Applaus]